I like that.
You're like very easy to talk to you.
Kind of funny.
I mean,
I don't know if I was laughing with you or nothing at you.
Okay.
A viral New York Times article featured 36 questions that could supposedly make
any two people fall in love.
We want it to see what would happen if we ask these questions to two complete
strangers on a blind date.
My name is Azariah.
I'm single like alone,
100%.
Honestly,
I could say I know exactly what I'm looking for in a person.
Someone fun,
adventurous,
outgoing,
likes kids.
It'd be dope if she also loved God.
Ambition is cool.
If someone that doesn't need me.
It's like a number one factor though.
The anticipation is like killing me though.
It's like when you're about to go on a roller coaster,
any takes forever to start
up.
Hi.
Hey,
how are you?
This is interesting.
It is interesting.
I'm Nikki.
I am 26 years old.
I'm hoping to find a best friend.
I think it's very important to bond with somebody.
Um,
and to have that kind of connection before even thinking about taking it to the
next step.
It's like 37 different types of tea.
Is there a green tea?
There's a green package or the new lady for green baggage's down meals so I
could calm my nerves.
You nervous?
No.
Am I saying it right?
Camera Male Cam a mile?
I think so.
I'm going to go with Earl gray.
Do you have a secret hunch of that?
How you will die?
I feel like I know for a fact I'm not going to die in a car accident.
Like yeah,
like 100%.
I've came too close to too many times.
I feel like God is just like,
Naw Bro,
that's not there.
Well yeah,
I'm so messed up in the head.
I would think I would die like probably getting swallowed by it.
What,
what is the probability of that?
I mean,
I'm just saying I can't even see like it's so easily avoidable though.
I'm telling you it's going to happen that way.
Nobody's car.
All right.
Is there something that you dreamed of doing for a long time?
And if so,
why haven't you done it?
I have this thing where I feel like since I was a loner girl,
I just felt like I'm Sif Savine entertainer.
Like I want to perform in front of millions of people.
Sing,
dance.
Like the words,
I feel like I haven't pursued it.
I don't know why.
Maybe I'm scared.
Maybe I'm just lazy.
Maybe I just don't have the passion for it.
But,
uh,
yeah,
I would say that that's the one thing that I know I think about condoms.
What about you?
Um,
actually I would say no.
Like everything that I've dreamed of doing they're like want to do in life is
like something I'm working towards now and that,
that kind of,
um,
change the past,
like year in my life,
I was like,
dude,
like life is for living and I'm tired of like,
like journals or whatever,
or like a bucket list.
It's like I don't want to have that and just like wait until I'm at a certain
point to start trying to accomplish it.
For me,
I feel like it'll happen when it will happen.
So I don't face it.
Maybe that's not the right way to look at it.
That's why I do it.
I'm a big believer in like,
and like God's timing,
you know?
I think when we
Jamaica we say when when minor plan got away,
when men are plan got away.
Yeah,
no,
it's kind of like you're making plans in the meantime guys like wifing cause I
don't know if I explained it right,
but it sounds like something from the book of proverbs that
how she'd go to Jamaica.
How do you feel about your relationship with your mother?
My mom is like,
she's dope.
That was my best friend.
She,
she raised me and made me the man I am,
you know,
she taught me so much and like my dad wasn't always in my life.
So my mom was like their life and she found a letter.
I wrote her in 2016 and it was like basically me saying like,
I'm sorry for not listening to you.
I'm sorry for thinking that I knew better than you.
You're the best thing that ever happened to me.
Odd is like super sentimental stuff and I reread read it and then she proceeded
to show me a picture of me coming out of her stomach and I was like,
Yo,
this is weird.
But yeah,
she so,
all right.
What about you?
What am I doing?
Your Mama?
So I grew up with my mom,
not there.
Like I feel like I can count on one hand how many times I've seen her in my life
or how many times I've remembered her there.
I don't know why she left.
I don't like blame her.
It just kind of was like,
my mom's not here.
My Dad is,
you know,
I would go like years without hearing from her.
Sometimes I would,
um,
you know,
call her just to hear her voice and she just be like,
I can't talk right now.
I'm busy.
But,
um,
it's kind of just made me think that if I do bring a child into this world,
I would never be that.
And I love her,
but it's like I,
I don't necessarily agree with being what she's right.
The choices she's made,
but you know,
it's made me who I am.
Yeah.
I mean I just met but I think that like you still a hell of a woman.
You obviously you were saying just having,
I like the way you carry yourself.
Hello woman.
Damn,
I don't like you.
Yeah.
You saw it was a question you played yourself.
No,
it wasn't good.
It was a good answer though.
That was cool.
Complete the sentence.
I wish I had someone with whom I could share that's about the thought.
An entire cheesecake from the cheesecake factory with cause like,
oh they cheesecake is bomb,
but I don't want them calories.
Yeah.
Nailed it.
Yes.
You don't want them calories because you know it's like a thousand calories per
slice.
Three slices.
Exactly.
A whole can
of whipped cream,
extra whip.
No low fat.
That's how you have achieved.
Sounds like that's how you have a heart attack too.
But he's like die happy though,
you know,
I'm,
I'm saying if this is the one thing I really want in life and I had to Geeky boy
that happened,
I would choose a cheesecake and I'm just saying and me,
I wish I had someone with whom I could share.
I think it's just going to meet Courtney told the truth.
I guess somebody could share life with.
You know,
I think at the end of the day like you can be so independent and a man or a
woman of your own,
but going to the grocery store is way more fun with somebody who,
you know,
going on a hike is way more fun with somebody there.
So I want to know that I have somebody you know there cause I'm always there for
people's,
I'd be like,
I don't question it.
I'm just like open,
ready Gus?
What's up?
No,
I do that.
I actually want to change my answer a little bit to that.
I can't do,
oh,
this is crazy.
He says without speaking,
he's staring into each other's eyes for four minutes.
Like first of all,
that number is,
I'll start the timer.
All right.
I'm up here.
Okay.
Uh,
that was very refreshing.
I really didn't know what to expect or who to expect going into it,
so I'm kind of a little bit impressed.
Have you know how it played out?
Yeah,
she's dope.
He's got good style.
Um,
she's fine.
She's seemed like she respects herself well.
She's the type of girl you would bring home to your mother.
Hmm.
Ooh.
Oh,
he's very funny.
I kind of get a vibe that he's very smart,
like he's advanced,
like beyond his years.
I could see me and Azariah chilling on a daily.
Wow.
That was not four minutes.
It felt a little shorter.
Right.
I couldn't use breaking rules.
Okay.
We'll be back.
All right.
You're going to come back.
Come back.
I'm to leave and I'm gonna come back and I'll see you later.
All right.
Do you remember him?
That was it.
Second day.
Yeah.
I hesitated.
That was weird.
Um,
but like I would like and if she's not like that's dope to um,
self love,
you know.
But no,
she was fine.
She was definitely fine if not like I'm sure we will be like good friends as
well.
So I think that's what's dope about it.
I yeah,
I do.
We have to call it a date though.
I'd be like,
I psych myself out with that word because it's intense and pretty personnel from
me,
but we could definitely go get ice cream or cheese.
Kay.
When they asked you if you would go on the second day,
what'd you say?
Yes or no?
I'm kind of said,
yeah.
Yeah.
Dang.
That's Matt.
I'm going to say
it is.
You say it?
Yeah.
It was like we could go get cheesecake or something.
Right?
100% I'll have is your slice.
It's okay.
Yeah.
I'll have your cheesecake,
whatever.
Thanks for watching.
TV for two t for two is a series where we set up people on blind dates.
As always,
there is no script.
Yes.
So let us know what you think in the comments.
He's like,
and subscribe to our channel for more videos and we'll see you next time.